the new Galaxy S 10 is here and it's
packin some pretty impressive battery
life but what if there is a way to
significantly increase the amount of
battery life you can get out of it well
from the results I found in this test
there is and it's by using night mode on
the galaxy s 10 which you can easily
toggle on in the notification panel many
of you know that the s 10 uses an OLED
display just like many other phones on
the market but what you might not know
is that displaying black or dark pixels
uses much less power compared to white
ones this test by sank 9 shows just how
much more power the color white takes on
OLED displays compared to black and with
red and green taking significantly less
power than blue now if you've got a
phone with an LCD display like the
iPhone 10 R this won't work because
unlike OLED it lights up the whole
display panel with OLED each pixel is
individually backlit so if it's
displaying true black it's completely
turned off and isn't using any power so
to test this out we displayed the reddit
homepage which is almost completely
white and measured the battery drain
after 2 hours and then we did the same
thing using Samsung's night mode enabled
before we began we closed background
apps set the power mode to optimized
turned off the blue light filter turned
off adaptive brightness and set the
brightness to the max to show just how
big of a difference night mode can make
if you're maxing out the brightness I
use Samsung's browser for this since
Chrome isn't currently affected by night
mode but Android q is bringing a dark
mode to Chrome soon so that's pretty
exciting now let's get into our battery
test after spending two hours on the
reddit homepage with night mode turned
on the battery went from a hundred
percent to 92% which is actually really
impressive considering the phone was at
maximum brightness we then charged it
back up to a hundred percent turned off
night mode and ran the test again this
time the battery went from a hundred
percent to a much lower 80 percent
that's a pretty decent difference for
simply turning on night mode and that's
with power mode set to optimize now
imagine if we used high performance mode
which makes the display even brighter
also if we would have extended the test
until the battery fully drained just
enabling night mode would make the
battery last an extra 15 hours compared
to having it disabled so anyone who does
a lot of browsing
right or whitepages should definitely
take advantage of night mode to save
some extra battery life but wait there
are even more things you can do simply
using a black or dark wallpaper compared
to the stock wallpaper will help save
battery life as well
sank 9 also tested brightness versus
battery consumption and if you look at
this graph you'll see the battery drain
shot through the roof when above 80
percent brightness so make sure you
don't go above that if you care about
battery life even better just use
adaptive brightness and it'll adjust to
match your environment this way you're
not wasting battery power while you're
indoors another important thing to
mention is that you should set your
screens himout duration to as short as
is convenient for you if you set it to
10 minutes and constantly forget to turn
off your screen your battery drain much
more quickly finally if you're running
low on battery and need to stretch it
out a few more hours Samsung's built-in
battery saving mode works incredibly
well if this video helps you out make
sure to LIKE and hit subscribe so you
don't miss out on more videos like this
one thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]